way back when it was very much a
gentlemen's club and they all kind of
got together and they saw an
entrepreneur and they said I'll throw a
little money in I'll throw a little
money in and and why don't we just say
we'll split it with the entrepreneur
5050 well that that did very well and
and so more money went in more people
watched more people realize that hey I
can do that too and so it has spread and
venture capital and entrepreneurship has
spread to where now rather than me going
door to door and knocking or knocking on
any door that said something software
now I am barage we have something like
20,000 business plans that come to my
email address every year a year yeah and
Wow so we're and I'd get to fund about
20 or 30 of them but you can also
distribute the ones that you think -
these don't work so but there are lots
of other venture capitalists there are
lots of ways to do venture capital there
was the possibility that I cos would
replace venture capital crypto Bitcoin
have really kind of changed things
eventually I believe that that I'll be
able to raise a fund in Bitcoin put it
out in Bitcoin and have the
entrepreneurs pay their employees and
suppliers in Bitcoin and then have the
whole thing build into a smart contract
so that my investors get exactly what
they're due at the exact time they're
due yes and and it could end up being a
really great experience and and
inclusive stake holding to consumers
always think that gives lawyers and
accountants more they can give you more
abstract advice rather than the boring
stuff that they that they have to spend
90% of their time doing kind of brings
it brings up AI I one way to look at the
world is everything is going to be
replaced by AI so just think about what
you're what part of your job is mundane
yes that will be replaced by AI and then
think how will you respond how do you do
better with this new world and it's kind
of fun to think about I I could there
are a lot of things that I do
repetitively and I would be happy to do
those by AI so that I was freed up to do
other things to your creative flow
States